[Music]
please I need my bag I took the wrong
one off the carousel it has some highly
classified material in it I'm sorry can
I help you didn't realize Jack Ryan flew
commercial oh great yeah pity comments
that's exactly what the situation needed
we're human college with Ainsley - I
always sort of Ainsley Duffy and Craig
is more of a trio no there are always
four of us I'm the funny one everyone's
always like dude is out and I'm like
I'll see you come be genuinely upsets me
when you do that do we really have to go
to this party your friends don't even
like me what are you talking about my
friends love you I think I'm trashy and
that my boobs are fake which they are
but your friends don't know that Maya
this is my boyfriend catch weight this
is cash his father works at the airport
maybe he could help behind that cute guy
did you call him Ryan Gosling dipped in
caramel I did not say that
have you ever had the feeling you've
gone down the wrong path like somewhere
along the line you've made a bad choice
and now it's too late to go back I feel
like I literally everyday I can't
believe you trust up for him I didn't
you're wearing a padded bra let me hug
your bouquet
[Music]
doesn't one told me you show up for the
people who matter the most to you
you don't think upon me too
this is why I have friends like you
[Music]
love who find the way bro
but our way here just because he doesn't
[Music]
you
you